he's yours but you didn't even say
anything that's right no winter I played
that perfectly' and kept quiet and
keeping quiet is not easy for me I mean
you guys know I'm not allowed back into
three movie theaters Kenny gets the
handoff boo to the tent she's at the
five she's got one man to beat and scars
touchdown I guess that answers the
question of whether Carol still has her
real hips on CBS so you say your life
kind of mirrors Carol it mirrors Carol
her kids are out of the house my kids
are out of the house she's embarking on
this new adventure as a doctor she's to
be a high school science teacher she's
divorced so she's you know reframing her
life it's new for me in the sense that
I'm first-time exec producing the show
and there's a lot of responsibilities
that come with that and it's good
because it's challenging me I am having
kind of stress dreams where I'll be like
in a house that I'm remodeling and I
don't know if it's working and it's
costing a lot of money and I know that's
like a reflection of trying to build a
show yes you know like can I do this
isn't going to look good you know so
it's it's it's good though it keeps your
brain going active yeah yeah I'm the
same way I've never done anything like
that right it's a lot different level of
pressure right yeah but you were amazing
this is crazy and I can't believe I
didn't know this because that's an
injustice for how hard you must have
been working but you raised for toddlers
while doing Everybody Loves Raymond the
first season of Raymond I had a
three-year-old a one-year-old and I was
pregnant with the third and then the
third season I had my fourth I'll see
sections and I don't know how because
now working on Carol with no kids at
home
I'm not exhausting how I did it with
four kids I used to get up in the
morning and my first thought was I could
really use a beer right
just thinking about getting through the
day and when I got home you know I'd get
the boys to bed I'd pour a big glass of
red wine you know and and I one night I
was drinking the wine and my son Joe
called me back upstairs so I ran up and
I said I leaned down and I said what is
it honey and he looked at me he said mom
you smell like communion like it's
because I go down there and pray for you
boys oh good so where are your sons
these days so the two oldest are in
Nashville yes of my oldest son is in a
band called forest fire gospel choir
they're very good but he also works at
Adele's did you ever eat yeah yeah yeah
yeah the second one is still lipid
living they're also just working third
ones here in LA fourth one is at the
Ohio State University my alma mater
that's a guess you have any Buckeyes
here ho H o H not yard you have to say
okay everybody
yeah so we're adjusting but it's great I
love when they come home yeah I know I
always feel like it's my husband looking
forward to it we have a three-year-old
and he's still looking for like he's
like it's gonna be so exciting Rhea is a
wonderful age they are nature though but
yeah he's a boy yeah we call it Tuesday
fine threes are the devil has access
from inside their body and I need an
exercise rink a communion every night I
drink a lot of community it wasn't my
fault Jesus changed that water yes I
don't need water are you bothering them
to have grandkids yet though because
they're another on the house oh yes in
fact I do it nationally like every talk
show I go on okay where's that what
camera should I look at this one right
here okay boys I'm just letting you know
the first one that gives me a grandchild
gets the house
I just got them all out of the house and
now I want more back here I know I want
more kids my husband doesn't it's super
interesting um speaking of kids Oh tell
us about your work with World Vision you
do a lot of work with it yeah and that's
another part of my second act I think
they're the biggest provider of clean
water in the world and they started the
sponsorship program where you can
sponsor a child but they've done this
cool new thing now called chosen and
it's $39 a month but instead of World
Vision just sending you a picture of a
child and saying would you like this
child you send your picture to World
Vision and they take it into a community
and they put all the pictures up and the
child picks you and then you get a
letter from the child telling you why
they picked you it's really rewarding
it's really exciting and consistency
with one person that's right that's so
it kids I mean you would know the writer
then even before kids with any
consistency well and I've traveled a lot
with World Vision of Zambia Jordan
Uganda Rwanda and you know people are
the same everywhere I was traveling with
one of the World Vision workers from
Rwanda and we're in the car for a long
time who's telling you about having to
go home that week and a go to the
wedding of one of his wife's coworkers
and he was complaining he's like I don't
know any of these people at her office
and I'm like what happens at home I'm
like it doesn't matter if you're in
Africa or the US like marriage is the
same ever no one wants to go to the
office Christmas party I'm just kidding
aren't just gonna be awesome guy I think
it just shows you how we're really all
the same everywhere and this world
vision shows of program is a great way
to connect as your child picked you yet
but I have not heard of where who my
child is yet
yeah that's so interesting I'm waiting
to well we asked World Vision for the
video of your child would you like to
see
[Applause]
[Music]
or less well right away because I was so
sweet that was really special you guys
will going to do that that was so
special it's a great thing to do as a
Christmas gift to yourself you get a lot
more back my mother does that at
Christmas she'll give us think like
she'll be fun account for this fan
that's right your vision has a catalog
where if you if you can't sponsor a
child maybe just something you can buy
chickens for a family yes they share it
with the rest of the village it's a gift
that keeps on giving
it's wonderful I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this